hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the senior associate editor at the new
statesman rachel kunliff and the sun's
political editor harry cole they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight welcome to you both thank you
both very much for coming on and doing
this
let's see what's on some of those front
pages the financial times here's the gas
prices could be among the factors to
propel inflation beyond 18
next year
soaring inflation is also the lead for
the times
the eye says liz trust has come under
fire for backtracking on a promise to
hold an emergency budget if she gets
into number 10
instead downgrading it to a so-called
fiscal event
the guardian reports that when mistrust
was environment secretary her department
cut millions of pounds in funding from
initiatives to keep sewage off the
country's beaches something which has
recently become a significant problem
according to the telegraph proposals are
being made to double payments to uk
households who host ukrainian refugees
to encourage families not to withdraw
from the scheme at the end of its first
six-month term
the metro is criticizing people who
misuse a and e departments including one
person who walked in complaining of
dandruff
and the star says that having a nap at
work is good for us and makes us more
productive according to research
do text or tweet if you spot me nodding
off a reminder though that by scanning
the qr code you can see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch along with us and to go through
those papers are rachel cunliffe and
harry cole
lots of good selections uh for us this
evening guys um the financial times
we're starting off with with the uh
british edition of the financial times
uh the these projected inflation figures
18
rachel it's eye watering isn't it this
this is one city analysts that have
suggested this citibank of have
suggested they fear it could reach that
high um
in terms of the political impact that
this will have it's enormous isn't it
it is enormous uh there is also a sense
though that we we see these figures on
the front pages of of the newspapers and
they keep getting higher and higher the
inflation rate keeps getting higher uh
it was predicted that it was going to be
13 in december now you've got this um
analysis suggesting 18 by january you've
also got the increase in the energy
price cap which feels less cap like the
more we go on uh
energy bills expected to go up to over 3
500 pounds in the october price cap rise
uh then again to
for 4 000 in january here in the ft
predicted 5800 uh by by april
there is almost a point at which the
numbers sort of start to lose their
meaning and it just becomes sort of
chaos and an economic devastation but
they haven't lost their meaning this is
a very key challenge that you would
expect to be the the national priority
for any government uh unfortunately we
don't really have a government at the
moment we have a caretaker government
and a government in waiting and so when
they're stuck in this holding pattern
until the uh the sixth of september when
we might get a prime minister and top on
their priority list will be exactly this
inflation and energy prices
and harry we're hoping we know we're
going to get the energy figures on
friday in terms of this price cap but
the predictions for that too uh coming
along uh you know we've got inflation on
one track and we've got these spiraling
energy costs on the other of course
they're they're affecting each other but
it it's we're not expecting good news on
friday are we
no i am and also they've tweaked the
rules as rachel says the cap is actually
not really a cap at all anymore because
it's going to change every three months
and um the wilder expectations um you
know by january this could be hitting
five and a half thousand pounds a
phenomenal amount of money that's going
to have a dire impact on people's bank
accounts um both the candidates now are
in
they're actually as i said
on this show before there's not actually
a massive amount of difference really
between those two candidates now liz
trusts uh quasi quartet who's expected
to be her chancellor both promising help
with the vulnerable the labour party
have sort of set the bar pretty high
with their sort of universal bailout i
suspect liz trust and quasi cartoon will
go for something a little bit more
targeted but um it's also the the impact
on business that needs to be remembered
it's not just households that are gonna
be suffering this summer hospitality
firms small firms that have only really
been getting back on their feet since
the pandemic um and now you know being
hit by crippling crippling business um
business costs for their energy and so
they're going to need
something small businesses especially so
yeah an intro from from hell for um for
a new uh for a new administration
and rachel moving on to the eye they're
they're saying that liz trust is going
to you turn on having a budget we were
expecting the 21st of september there to
be a sort of mini budget the eye is
suggesting uh that she's going to call
it a fiscal event rather than a mini
budget because that will avoid detailed
scrutiny i mean
she's not going to be able to avoid
detailed scrutiny issue because as
you've both pointed out we've had a
whole summer where nothing has been done
about all of the cost of living fears
that people have people are going to
want to see action when the new prime
minister is put in place
they're definitely going to want to see
action the question is how thoroughly
the strategy is is costed and what else
has to fall by the wayside because of
that so the the io is reporting that the
reason for downgrading the emergency
budget to a so-called fiscal event isn't
just to do with the the words it's to do
with the fact that when you have a
budget you have to get economic
forecasts and you have to cost
everything else and you have to show in
in this case how inflation
will impact the government's ability to
balance its budget and
maintain physical responsibility now uh
but by by not doing that the implication
is that liz trust can go ahead with the
tax cuts that she's already promised and
a full package of support that harry
alluded to i'm sure she's working very
hard on
and can worry about whether that's paid
for in in debt or in other ways a bit
later because the inflation that we're
seeing will have eroded the extra
budgetary surplus that she was playing
with in order to make those promises now
i i kind of think it's it obviously it's
an important point whether the budget
gets balanced and
very that those forecasts are important
it should definitely be done but i think
when it comes to the entry of the new
prime minister it is going to be a case
of how quickly can we move to get help
to the people who need it the most to
prevent
thousands millions of people from going
hungry or cold this winter that's going
to be
the priority work out the costings later
just like we saw in covered and of
course given that all of the polls
appear to be suggesting that this trust
will be the next prime minister although
you know we all know as journalists not
to trust the polls um harry
people are now going back over her
previous record in previous departments
and this brings us onto the guardian
page one and the story that that we've
been uh covering today about the amount
of sewage on our beaches and the amount
of the water companies have been uh
emitting onto the beaches and they're
now saying suggesting that it was all
down to liz trust cutting money for them
when she was environment minister
yeah two things just one very quickly on
the iframe page i think it's a little
bit unfair because the obr basically a
proper forecast would take 10 weeks so
what yeah what you're saying is actually
if they wanted to move quickly on cost
of living they need to do this sooner or
later and actually if you wait for that
full costings which will come in the
spring anyway um
it would take 10 weeks for the obr to
put that together and that basically
argument is actually we'll have 10 weeks
to to to to to wait so i think it's a
little bit unfair to suggest it's sort
of deliberately trying to
observate where the money's coming from
what i find really interesting about
this guardian front page is labor have
woken up um and they have clearly had a
look at the polls and they have clearly
decided that liz trust is going to win
because this is a labor attack uh story
tonight it's been put together by their
shadow environment team they um you know
they can they can tell the political
toxicness of the of the beaches and the
rivers of flowing uh you know
overflowing with sewage um it has to be
said i was in france you know uh last
week beaches were closed after a major
thunderstorm in a similar way to the way
they have been here this is you know the
alternative is this sewage flows out of
manhole covers and into the streets of
mp's constituents and if it doesn't go
in the sea yes there is an argument that
you know austerity right across
whitehall and the environment agency in
particular had to find some 200 million
pounds worth of efficiency savings as
they called it yeah i think it's gonna
be a rich scene for the opposition they
seem to have already decided that
actually richie sooner is not really
worth their time time to hammer trust
and talking about rishi sunak rachel uh
the telegraph page one uh apparently
he's not going to be serving in liz
truss's cabinet i mean i suppose no
surprise here if she does end up being
her prime minister that she wouldn't
necessarily want rishi on her t her team
kind of come back on something that that
harry said i'm so pleased that he
mentioned international comparisons when
it comes to sewage on beaches uh we've
got some new statesman data analysis up
today that shows that yes pollution is
an issue across europe but britain's
beaches and river water is
almost the most polluted and the
dirtiest across the whole of europe and
i think harry's absolutely right that
the story here really is about liz trust
it's about the attitude of the the
cameron osborne austerity project which
saw any slack in the system at all as
wasteful spending that could be sort of
trimmed down for a slimmer fitter state
and we're actually finding out lately
that a lot of the slack in the system
was there for a reason via extra
capacity when it comes to hospitals and
healthcare or when it comes to uh money
to make sure that the water companies
are behaving appropriately and
monitoring how much sewage they put in
our seas and our rivers as for synax
serving in the cabinet well we've come a
long way from that early debate when
they were both so magnanimous and
chivalrous towards each other would you
would you invite your opponent to serve
in your cabinet of course i would i
think they're brilliant i think this
concept eight weeks later beyond that
yeah in terms of nasty
quite a while ago looking at some of the
inside pages now and um harry actually
this is actually still on the front page
this is the telegraph uh refugee host
cash should be doubled uh this is lord
harrington and he's suggesting that
families who are hosting ukrainian
refugees should get more than 300 pounds
a month which is they get at the moment
350 should be increased to 700 largely
because of the cost of living crisis but
but also perhaps some kind of
recognition that it's not easy having
somebody in your home and it's for some
of these people it's been six months
yeah this has been bubbling around for a
few days now and um lord harrington has
decided to i think we put his name to uh
quotes that were already starting to
appear um over the weekend we're into a
strange place now though because um you
know it's tough for us to look at that
story like that and work out whether
he's saying that because it's going to
happen because he is the minister in
charge and he's you know as as ministers
do they sort of float ideas and trail
them before the official announcement or
whether he's almost sort of lobbying um
lobbying his successor or the next
government to to do something because
um he thinks he's going to be out of a
job or perhaps he wants to catch the
incoming administration's eye so it's a
weird one at the moment because there's
lots of these sort of stories up here
where ministers who are in the caretaker
sort of regime the ones that haven't
resigned stayed in their jobs but
clearly you know not um you know not
making massive policy decisions seem to
be popping up in the papers all you know
the last few weeks with big ideas and
new ideas not actually saying they're
going to do them but they want to do
them and we don't actually it's almost
sort of a phony war we don't actually
know whether it's going to happen or
whether they're just lobbying
rachel i mean do you think in principle
it's a good idea
i i think it's a very sad indictment of
our present situation
that uh a cost of living crisis that is
primarily sparked by the increasing the
price of oil because russia chose to
invade ukraine we're now seeing
households according to this article
who are only able to meet their
day-to-day living costs because of that
thank you payment they get from from
hosting ukrainian refugees it's all come
full circle in a rather tragic way but
lord harrington makes the point in that
article that these are individual
households who are
welcoming refugees into their homes and
if they weren't doing that it would be
the state that was picking up the bill
through rental accommodation
for them and and therefore they are in a
way sort of saving the state money i
think a more important point is is
helping those ukrainians uh work and and
set up lives here if that is indeed what
they want to do and making sure that
they can support themselves rather than
relying on people's spare rooms
okay a final a quick story from the
international financial times it's front
page um this is apple stuff they're not
as keen to go
back into the office are they hara you
two are both providing excellent
examples of people working from home
this evening i'm less so here in the
studio but but apple stuff they say
they've been able to do exceptional work
from home
we'd love to come back to the studio one
day
i miss those days uh and i have to say i
have been in the office all day today it
was my first day back up the holiday but
i'd even put a tie on um look yeah this
is something that's gonna happen right
across the the developed world um you
know you see it at the moment uh the
train i took in this morning yes it's
middle of august but it was pretty quiet
um
more and more people are actually you
know as a sort of silver lining of the
pandemic looking at how they
um you know how they can how they can do
their jobs more effectively they argue
um i'm sure the uh the summers summer's
weather
um has helped um some people uh work
from home i i suspect this
speaking
and it does depend on your job
um but look this is this is a debate
that's gonna rage and major rage because
once you give someone a taste of freedom
like that it's very hard to take it away